ea killed a harry potter mmo because
they didn't believe in the long-term
prospects of the ip yes you heard me
correctly in fact a former ea executive
confirmed it just last week why would
they do such a thing in an interview
with the real brandalorian kim salzer
who worked at ea as a director of
product marketing from 2000 to 2003 said
quote a big one for me because i was so
personally involved in it and it's such
a huge ip that it's lived on is a online
massively multiplayer game for harry
potter close quote i'm sorry
what this is something harry potter fans
have wanted for years but wait there's
more salzer went on to say quote we did
all the research we had the beta built
it was a combination of an offline
online experience where we would
actually mail stuff to the kids like
prizes and ribbons and stuff like that
thoroughly researched very confident in
the success of this okay look i know ea
has a somewhat bad reputation in the
video game industry but they did an okay
job especially with some of the early
harry potter games and look let's be
real here it definitely seems like
salzer and the team behind this had a
passion for the project she even talked
about a lot of the research they did
with kids who were fans of harry potter
it also sounds like they were developing
this completely separate from those
mainline video games that were released
with each new movie so hopefully they
would have been given the time they need
to make it successful now when it comes
to mmos fantasy and mmos they just go so
well together i mean think we've seen
final fantasy world of warcraft you also
have the elder scrolls online i mean
some of the biggest mmos are set in a
fantasy world i mean i really think
that's that i know salzer is spot on
here this would have been an incredible
success so why wouldn't ea in their
infinite wisdom not jump all over this
well salsa addressed that too quote but
it was killed for lack of a better term
because ea was going through some
changes at the time and they just didn't
know or believe that that ip would have
a shelf life of longer than a year or
two close quote well i think it's safe
to say you messed that one up ea of
course hindsight is everything but now
looking back we can all see this ip has
had incredible staying power think about
all the movies all the books all the
stage play i mean there's a theme park
for harry potter huge huge staying power
ea really missed a big opportunity here
now would ea have been able to deliver a
top-notch experience i think that's
another question of course salzer is
going to talk very positively about the
work that she and her team did but it
does sound like they were pretty early
in this and who knows how these things
go as they move forward as they get
closer to the finish line as they
actually start happening would
everything have fell into place for this
to be a great mmo i have no idea i've
actually already seen quite a few
comments from people talking about how
they are glad this didn't happen because
ea would have just screwed it up so i
mean that is certainly a possibility as
well perhaps the biggest question though
is there's still a chance this could
happen in the future well we all know
that avalanche is working on hogwarts
legacy an action rpg not an mmo an
action rpg set in the wizarding world
and this game is scheduled to release in
2022 but as someone who has been
covering that game extensively i can't
tell you how many times in the comments
i've had people say i want an mmo why is
it not an mmo in fact i would say there
are a fair number of people out there
who are kind of upset that it's an
action rpg and not an mmo now me
personally i'm not one of them i'm super
pumped about the action rpg but that
still doesn't mean that i wouldn't want
to see an mmo set in the wizarding world
at some point in the future you know as
excited as i am for hogwarts legacy i
can't lie i would still love to see an
experience that's set in a more vast
world that's kind of a living breathing
world where you can team up with friends
and it's just there's always something
to do i mean i just think about tackling
a big boss together with a group of
friends or going through a raid-like
activity with several different friends
all that sounds awesome to me and
honestly i've never really been an mmo
guy destiny kind of changed my
experience on that a little bit because
i got into destiny because i enjoy first
person shooters and thought hey this
might be kind of cool this sort of
looter mechanic honestly i just didn't
know how much i would enjoy that type of
game where you're grinding for new armor
grinding for new weapons and usually
doing it with a group of friends
seriously i was almost exclusively a
single-player gamer but something about
destiny just hooked me and i actually
made i can honestly say that i made
friends through playing the destiny
video game that i still talk to in real
life destiny really helped me to see
just how incredible those experiences
can be when you're working with a group
of people to accomplish these just
seemingly insurmountable tasks and
honestly i think the wizarding world
would be an absolutely perfect setting
for an mmo and it would be incredibly
successful if done right okay let's have
a little fun here just think about all
the insane possibilities imagine that
you actually go to school at hogwarts or
who knows if they want to go really big
you could go to any wizarding world
school let's even say they just keep it
with hogwarts you go to hogwarts for
seven years and then after that you pick
a career you can go about that career i
mean just think about all the amazing
wizarding world careers out there
obviously they couldn't include
everything but even you can include like
a handful five or six of the most
adventurous wizarding world careers that
is just a game honestly that i want to
play of course it would not be ea
working on this as they no longer
control the ip when it comes to video
games now it's all under the direction
of wb and port key games now when you
think about port key games this label
was created specifically for harry
potter video games now i don't think you
go to the trouble of creating a label if
you're only planning a couple of games
off this so perhaps we haven't heard the
end of this perhaps there is still a
chance that we could see a harry potter
mmo at some point in the future again i
don't think you go to the trouble of
creating and setting up this label if
you're only going to release a handful
of games and then call it a day but i
want to hear from you guys in the
comments would you like to see a harry
potter or just a wizarding world mmo and
if so what would you like to see in it
if you found my channel here for the
first time we have a ton of harry potter
video game content here in fact if you
want to catch up on all the latest
hogwarts legacy news then check out the
playlist on the left side of your screen
and if you'd rather sit back relax and
enjoy some old school harry potter let's
plays then check out the playlist on the
right side of your screen as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon